[Musique]
mes patates bien de chez nous des
nivernais au dépourvu d'esprit c'est
compliqué ok ça va ça a été la réponse 0
rue dumont secrétaire général adjoint de
républicains en charge de la jeunesse et
de la rénovation à député de la 7e
circonscription du pas-de-calais par son
club de lens je suis supporters de lens
depuis que je suis tout gamin et mon
père lui soutient le losc met à les
laisser en général bebel marié à calais
avec une calaisienne
évidemment je ne peux dire que général
de gaulle a vu ma coupe aujourd'hui je
dirais plutôt salon l'agriculture mais
premier j'ai bientôt je le connais c'est
pas la même coupe de cheveux
emmanuel petit savait marquer des buts
la dernière seconde
koh lanta particulier la recherche du
collier d'immunité ça peut servir en
plus haribo je suis un fan de dragibus
didier deschamps il ramène les étoiles
ni l'un ni l'autre
où ai-je pu berges et à thunder sur coup
un big mac en travaillant sur
l'allemagne
il songe à quand même si et christian
clavier
je pense à quelques points communs avec
avec christian jacob dans l'attachement
à la france
bistrot j'aime manger rapidement
j'aime les plats classiques steak frites
sens particulier c'est mon petit don
petits plaisirs confiture de fraises le
matin ça carbure la raclette la bonne
charcuterie et les patates bien de chez
nous plutôt couche tard j'ai énormément
de mal à me lever le matin les matinales
skin torture mais je peux travailler
sans aucun problème jusqu'à 2 heures du
matin mais robin or c'est plus difficile
pour se baigner mais les plages sont
beaucoup plus belle et beaucoup moins
souple et baron noir même si je suis
loin d'en remettre l'union européenne
aux briques cité-etat et une difficulté
un drame pour le territoire que je
représente
françois damiens ces caméras cachées
c'est vraiment plaisir et puis dit que
n'est qu'un de mes films favoris
[Musique]